Rob here with a GS news update the Xbox
one had a great holiday season
outselling the PlayStation 4 in November
and December but that reign of terror
has stopped the ps4 is now back on top
the holiday success for xbox could be at
least somewhat attributed to the fifty
dollar price drop allowing Xbox to
undercut the four hundred dollar
PlayStation for the Xbox price went back
up in January but only temporarily the
price went back to 350 again in the
middle of the month comparative January
of last year overall hardware sales in
the US are down 54 million dollars don't
freak out though because the MPD says
that combined hardware install base of
ps4 and Xbox one is close to sixty
percent higher than the overall hardware
totals for Xbox 360 and ps3 at the same
point in their life cycles hardware may
be down but software and accessory sales
are both up led by strong sales of dying
light it was sure nice to see Xbox one
on top for that two-month window it was
really nice let's see if they can pull
it off again up now remember for all of
your gaming news you go ahead you check
out gamespot com / news y'all ready for
this